Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Dans les années 80, mon pays a traversé
une période d'instabilité profonde.
Concrètement, mon pays
était en guerre civile.
Mais pudiquement, quand on parle
aujourd’hui de cette période,
on dit : « les événements ».
À vrai dire, ce mot valise
m’a toujours interrogée,
mais je ne sais pas ce qui s’est passé
et personne ne le sait vraiment.
Ou tout au mieux, chacun en possède
un tout petit morceau.
Partout dans le monde, les passés
problématiques sont nombreux.
Ils sont enfouis
dans les tiroirs des musées
aux côtés de la mémoire des colonisés,
des torturés et des opprimés.
Aujourd’hui, en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
ils refont surface,
dans les discours politiques,
sur les plateaux télévisés.
Ils sont présents à l’école,
dans les conflits des enfants.
Ils résonnent dans la rue
lors des manifestations.
Ils sont présents
dans les murmures des vieux,
comme on dit ici en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Ces passés problématiques ressurgissent
parce que le temps ne suffit pas
à faire disparaître la douleur,
il faut la soigner.
Mais comment faire ?
Après avoir tu de nombreuses exactions,
est-il possible de rétablir
cette vérité qui dérange ?
Restituer aux peuples colonisés
et opprimés leur mémoire
est un passage obligé.
Le but n’est pas de juger
ces passés, ni de les comparer.
Ni vous, ni moi, ne pouvons nous inventer
juge de la Cour pénale internationale.
Mais nous pouvons regarder
ces situations en face.
Nous pouvons faire, par exemple, en sorte
qu’un petit garçon de 3 ans et pendant
la Shoah avait comme seul tort d’être juif
ne grandisse pas avec comme seul objectif
la vengeance de sa mère.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie, on essaye
péniblement, laborieusement,
maladroitement parfois, d'avancer.
Les Néo-Calédoniens appellent au futur.
Mais de quel futur peut-on rêver
avec ces plaies toujours ouvertes ?
Cette période dite des événements
a été un traumatisme
pour de nombreux Néo-Calédoniens,
que ce soit pour les descendants
de bagnards comme moi,
certains délégitimés de leurs terres,
les Japonais, les populations kanak
dont la dignité a été bafouée,
les Vietnamiens, des contrats
de chair humaine, les Océaniens.
Tous,
tout le monde, à sa manière,
renferme son traumatisme.
À tel point qu’on aperçoit
encore ce boulet,
ce passé enchaîné à certaines chevilles,
comme du temps des bagnards.
En 88 puis en 98, la Nouvelle-Calédonie
a fait le choix de signer des accords,
mais ils n’ont pas permis
de réconcilier les mémoires.
Une de mes profs me disait souvent
que la mémoire n’est pas
le reflet exact et parfait du passé.
Elle en est une trace.
Ainsi, la mémoire est malléable,
fluctuante, amovible, biaisée,
faussée, reconstruite,
mais surtout, elle est propre à chacun.
Il y a donc différents types de mémoire.
La mémoire individuelle,
c’est-à-dire la mienne, la vôtre,
Monsieur ou la vôtre, Madame.
Lors d’un repas de famille,
on s’est tous déjà dit :
« Il raconte n’importe quoi,
le vieux Tonton. »
Alors oui, dans certains cas,
Tonton raconte n’importe quoi.
Mais dans d’autres cas, Tonton
est persuadé de raconter la vérité,
sa vérité, sa perception, son vécu,
sa mémoire à lui dans la grande Histoire.
Mais personne ne peut enlever à Tonton
son souvenir, qu’il soit biaisé ou non.
Alors imaginez-vous ce que ça peut donner
à l’échelle d’un pays tout entier,
à l'échelle d'une nation.
Puis il y a la mémoire collective,
c’est celle qui est communément
admise sans trop de variantes.
Par exemple, si on parle de foot,
que je vous dis « Coupe du monde »,
vous me répondrez « 98 »,
puis pour certains
« 2018, mais d’abord 98 »,
car le temps joue un rôle primordial
dans la mémoire collective.
Donc ces mémoires sont mouvantes.
Enfin, il y a la mémoire officielle.
C’est celle que
les autorités nous transmettent
via les manuels scolaires
ou les commémorations, par exemple.
Si on parle de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
on pense directement
aux 6 millions de Juifs tués,
à Hitler, aux camps de concentration.
Par contre, les anecdotes
personnelles de la guerre
restent des mémoires individuelles.
Lorsqu’elle est partagée de tous,
La mémoire officielle devient
alors Histoire avec un grand H
et symbole d'identité nationale.
Mais que se passe-t-il lorsque
les mémoires sont manipulées ?
Lorsque Tonton ment volontairement,
en omettant ou en accentuant tout ou
partie de ce qui s’est réellement passé ?
Lorsque les autorités imposent
la version officielle ?
En général, elles ne parviennent
pas à effacer nos souvenirs,
la mémoire officielle ne prend pas
le dessus sur la mémoire individuelle.
Si les autorités impose la version
officielle, il y a conflit des mémoires.
Mais nous aussi,
nous manipulons les mémoires,
Volontairement ou non.
Mais lorsque l’on refuse de parler
ou de se souvenir du passé,
nous les manipulons.
Le temps est long,
il est nécessaire
et se compte en générations.
Mais à lui seul, il ne suffit pas.
Le simple fait d’attendre que les victimes
passent à autre chose ne marche pas.
C'est même pire.
Aux enfants, on cache la vérité,
bien souvent pour les protéger,
mais inconsciemment,
on leur transmet nos émotions,
Ils les vivent ils les cultivars, alors
même que ce ne sont pas les leurs.
Les générations passent, la haine
et la volonté de vengeance demeurent,
parfois même grandissent,
et le vivre ensemble est
de moins en moins possible.
Comment faire alors
pour estomper cette douleur ?
Pour décharger les épaules de nos jeunes
de ces émotions
qui ne leur appartiennent pas.
C’est là tout l’objet de mes recherches :
les études de réconciliation,
les processus de réparation post-conflit,
la mémoire collective.
Au lendemain d’un conflit armé,
d’une colonisation ou d’une guerre civile,
les bourreaux sont si nombreux qu’il
serait impossible de tous les emprisonner.
Pour permettre ce vivre ensemble,
les États amnistient ces bourreaux.
Mais ça crée
une nouvelle sorte d’impunité.
Heureusement, d’autres méthodes existent.
Notamment la justice transitionnelle.
Elle repose sur cinq piliers :
la vérité,
la justice,
la réparation,
la garantie de non-répétition,
et la mémoire.
L’un ne peut aller sans l’autre.
Concernant les processus de réparation,
quatre étapes sont nécessaires.
D’abord, la reconnaissance publique.
« Voilà ce qu’il s’est passé. »
Puis, la responsabilité : endosser
le rôle d’anciens bourreaux.
« C’est moi qui ai fait ça. »
Ensuite, la question du pardon,
les excuses.
Et enfin la réparation matérielle,
donc symbolique
car aucune compensation ne viendra
remplacer la perte d’un proche.
Ça peut être une compensation
financière, une commémoration,
un monument aux morts, une restitution.
D’ailleurs,
de nombreux essais
ont été effectués dans le monde
en utilisant
cette justice transitionnelle.
Alors concrètement,
ça ressemble à quoi,
la justice transitionnelle ?
Au Rwanda, ce sont des gacaca
qui ont été utilisés.
Il s'agit d'une pratique ancestrale.
En 2001, on a utilisé les gacaca
dans le conflit des mémoires,
présent depuis le génocide.
Imaginez-vous, on a réuni
sur les lieux-mêmes des crimes
des victimes encore rescapées et bourreaux
avant de débattre de ce qui
s’était passé et obtenir la vérité.
Les débats étaient encadrés
par des personnes intègres.
Le but ? Laver le pardon.
Il s’agissait de faire éclater la vérité,
accélérer les procès
et mettre fin à l’impunité
pour encourager la réconciliation.
Le bourreau pouvait bénéficier
d’une réduction de peine,
et la victime de son droit à la vérité.
En Nouvelle-Zélande, le peuple Maori
a été colonisé par les Anglais.
En 1975, c’est un tribunal un peu spécial
qui est mis en place,
le tribunal de Waitangi.
Inspiré par le mouvement
des droits civiques aux États-Unis,
le peuple Maori s’est soulevé.
Au sein même de ce tribunal,
il pouvait déposer des requêtes,
comme une sorte de commission
d’enquête permanente.
Ils étaient auditionnés dans des marae,
un peu comme des cases traditionnelles,
et la Couronne signait
des actes de règlements
qui engageaient une reconnaissance,
des excuses officielles
et des réparations aux tribus,
parfois matérielles, parfois financières.
Et il en existe bien d’autres,
des exemples :
le Comité Vérité et Réconciliation
en Afrique du Sud,
l’instance Vérité Dignité en Tunisie,
les caravanes espagnoles de la mémoire.
Bien sûr, il est impossible de
comparer ces différentes méthodes.
À chaque pays, son traumatisme.
À chaque pays, sa douleur.
À chaque pays,
son processus de réparation.
Et en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
qu’est-ce qu’on a fait ?
Les Tonton Marcel, les Dédé, les Tatane,
les Joinville et tous les autres,
Ils en sont où ?
Pour ce qui est du contentieux
colonial avec la France,
les mémoires ont été façonnées
à tous les niveaux.
L'histoire est longtemps restée taboue.
Ce qui nous a plongé dans ce que
Louis-José Barbançon appelle
« le pays du non-dit ».
Et aujourd’hui, à mon sens,
nous en sommes là.
La reconnaissance officielle
de la colonisation
se trouve dans le préambule
de l’accord de Nouméa.
La première étape a donc été réalisée.
La responsabilité française y figure,
elle n’y est pas pleinement assumée,
l’histoire calédonienne manque
encore cruellement de lumière.
La troisième étape,
les excuses officielles,
sans qu’il ne s’agisse de repentance,
n’a jamais été abordée.
Mais paradoxalement, alors même que les
étapes précédentes sont restées timides,
quelques gestes de réparation
ont été menés :
la réforme foncière,
la remise de l’acte de possession,
la démarche pour la place de la paix,
et dernièrement, le mémorial dédié
à Ataï, grand guerrier kanak.
En terre kanak, des processus de
rituels de réconciliation ont été menés.
En 98, entre les familles des victimes
de la grotte d’Ouvéa et les gendarmes.
En 2004, entre plusieurs familles
autour de l’assassinat de
Jean-Marie Tjibaou et Yeiwéné Yeiwéné.
Et tout récemment en 2021 à Fonwhary,
entre La Foa et Farino,
à la mémoire d’Ataï et de son sorcier,
entre l’État et les instances coutumières.
D'ailleurs, dans la coutume kanak,
on retrouve nos quatre étapes.
La rencontre est souvent solennelle.
En déposant une coutume de pardon,
la partie fautive reconnaît les faits,
admet ses responsabilités
et demande pardon.
Ces trois étapes sont presque simultanées.
L'autre partie répond pour montrer
qu'elle accepte les excuses.
Et en guise de réparation,
une messe œcuménique est donnée.
Mais à l'échelle du pays,
il reste tant à faire.
Il nous faut imaginer ce processus
de réparation calédonien.
Comme l’a dit le Haut-Commissaire
de la République en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
il fut un temps où nous étions
les uns en face des autres.
Aujourd’hui, il est temps d’être
avec les uns à côté des autres.
Avec l'association Demain en commun, nous
souhaitons mettre en place un processus
de justice transitionnelle pour le pays.
Notre idée : s’inspirer des caravanes
espagnoles de la mémoire.
Un bus sillonnerait le pays pour
récolter et faire voyager la mémoire,
pour en montrer la diversité
et revisiter l’histoire officielle.
Les mémoires seraient recueillies
au sein même des communes
et constitueraient la matière nécessaire
aux prochaines étapes
du processus de réconciliation.
Nous souhaitons délier les langues.
Car le passé est devenu si lourd
qu’il empêche le futur de se construire.
Le futur doit devenir le projet commun
en se basant,
en s’appuyant sur un passé révélé,
pardonné,
réparé.
Sur un passé qu’on n’aura pas étouffé.
Pauleti. Merci.
(Applaudissements)